a Tik Tok influencer named Maddie made
this video about the silent walking
movement that she believes she pioneered
as I was about to go out on my first 30-
minute walk my sweet boyfriend
challenged me to walk without
distractions no airpods no podc no music
Just Me Myself and I and at first I was
like no my anxiety could never which is
probably what you're thinking and look
the first 2 minutes are Mayhem your mind
is racing you're going to have anxiety
something happens after 2 minutes where
your brain just gets into this Flow
State and suddenly you can hear yourself
I have no problem with silent walking I
think it's a very good practice the
problem is the ignorance that leads
these Tik Tok influencers to believe
that they came up with the idea
themselves she started a movement she
brags